[Music]
joining me now is Senator Josh Holly
member of the Senate Judiciary Committee
and the homeland security committee
Senator your response to all of these
efforts by Smith the Judiciary behind
him and the lack of oversight uh given
what's happened here with these
cases well Laura I will just say that
this is the most unbelievable incredible
abuse of the first amendment in our
Constitution that we have ever seen in
American history and that's no small
thing you know because we've had some
serious abuses in the past but look at
what this Administration is doing the
special counsel who's totally and
completely out of control he's obviously
doing the bidding of Joe Biden I mean he
is going after individual citizens here
let's be clear about this he is trying
to get the records of Twitter users who
just liked a tweet by Donald Trump or
who retweeted a Donald Trump post I mean
this is unbelievable stuff and I have to
tell you it reminds me of what happened
in Hong Kong with the Chinese Communist
party did there you know I had the
privilege of being in Hong Kong on the
streets with the protesters when China
was in the middle of their brutal
Crackdown and do you know what they did
they turned Hong Kong into a police
state they turned every CCTV camera all
over that City on the protesters they
followed them on their social media they
tracked them on their phones when you
look at what Jack Smith is doing here it
looks like the same exact thing this is
CCP tactics communist CH tactics used
against the American people all in
service of going after this president's
political opponents and Laura there's a
pattern here too I mean we now have
courts have said federal courts have
said that this Administration has
deliberately violated the first
amendment by coercing and working with
social media companies this is the
president deliberately and directly
ordering his white house to go to
Twitter to go to Facebook to go to
Instagram and to pressure them to censor
speech they don't like to take down
posts about school board meetings about
co uh about election issues about the
100 Biden laptop they did all of those
things in order the American people and
Senator the thing that I'm Blown Away by
and this is not directed at you is how
few members of the Republican Party have
really stood
and for what it and and as I said in the
angle silence is approval in this Cas
when the government is used against the
people who fund the government that's
tyranny and they're calling Trump an
authoritarian they're they're trying to
scare people that Trump's going to
execute people when he gets into Power
if he gets into Power again I mean where
where is the Senate leadership on this
where is any leadership on
this there there's no accountability and
you're absolutely right I mean this
ought to be the number one issue L this
is this is what how a police state
behaves I cannot emphasize this enough I
mean this is the abuse of government
power deliberately against anybody
anybody who disagrees with them anybody
who offers a political Viewpoint they
don't like they have you censored they
have you tracked they have you followed
this is absolutely outrageous and the
answer to this is people need to start
getting impeached for this stuff
Alejandra mayorcas he needs to be imp
Peach the homeland security director
Christopher Ray at the FBI his FBI
violated the First Amendment there need
to be consequences but what we're seeing
right now is is as you say it is silence
no and there's nothing that's a bigger
threat to democracy than this well
Senator I I appreciate your voice on
this I think the tcid approval is from
Senators who don't like Trump and they
don't understand that they're next on
the list they're next on The Chopping
Block uh Senator thank you so much hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else